So essentially what we're seeing in this
report is the CDC documenting the back end
of a crisis that started many years ago.
So despite all of the new efforts in place,
so many folks were exposed to
opioid therapy and entered into this
cycle of addiction and overdose, that
this report is essentially providing for us
statistics on the outcome of a
long-standing crisis.
Going forward, we can interrupt the exposure of patients to opioids on the front end
by providing procedural alternatives -- for example -- and other ways to manage pain
so that folks don't have to take pills.
The other way to interrupt the inflow is
through something we call here at Emory the Emory Opioid Stewardship Council,
which tracks and educates physicians about using opioids only in particular conditions,
in order to decrease the number of folks.
And then on the other side,
we're working to rehabilitate people who have already been exposed to opioids
and entering into this cycle,
using procedural options again,
as well as psychological counseling.